en la capital de tigre los líderes del
frente de liberación del pueblo están a
merced del ejército etíope el miércoles
el ultimátum del gobierno llegó a su fin
y se fue sin respuesta los líderes de
tigre ya dejaron claro que lucharían
hasta el final en un comunicado el
primer ministro de etiopía dijo que
había ordenado a las fuerzas
gubernamentales dar un golpe final a
make el capital de la región y agregó
que el ejército trataría de proteger a
los civiles pero también advirtió que no
habrá piedad para aquellos que no
lograron distanciarse de los
combatientes el gobierno afirma que los
tanques y los soldados han rodeado a la
ciudad en los últimos tres días
esperando que los líderes de tigre se
rindan la onu advirtió que la escasez en
la región se ha vuelto crítica esta foto
satelital muestra a los automovilistas
haciendo fila para cargar combustible
mientras las gasolineras se secan las
agencias de ayuda dicen que los combates
ya han obligado a desplazarse a más de
un millón de personas decenas de miles
han huido de tigre y han acabado aquí en
miserables campamentos al otro lado de
la frontera en sudan
sólo imaginen que para todos
literalmente para todo desde la comida
hasta el agua potable incluso para ir al
baño y lavarse las manos para todo
dependen de otra persona
a medida que la crisis se profundiza la
unión africana ha intentado mediar pero
sus repetidos intentos de improvisar un
acuerdo han sido rechazados por el
gobierno etíope